[музика]
стійкість українська особливість
характерна риса стійкість - це про
восьмирічну Люду з горенки яка просить у
Святого Миколая подарувати їй нову школу
з укриттям бо стару знищили рашисти і
місцева Влада вже готує проект відбудови
аби повернути школярам можливість
нормально вчитися водночас завдяки вже
облаштованим укриттям цього навчального
року ще півмільйона школярів змогли
нарешті повернутися
класі стійкість - це також і про Одеську
вчительку Марину Іванівну яка
включається на урок з автобуса що на 20
годин застряг в Сніжному заметі їх
оточують цих романтичні про всіх дітей
які не мають можливості ходити до школи
але попри все вчаться онлайн Наша ж
команда шукає і знаходить можливості
забезпечити їх сучасними гаджетами для
дистанційного навчання разом з
партнерами також створили мережу
цифрових освітніх центрів аби хоча б
частково відновити доступ до освіти у
тих областях де діти нині не можуть
ходити до школи стійкість однозначно
наша суперсила яка забезпечить Україні
стале майбутнє але її також треба
підтримувати та розвивати через освіту
зокрема тож цього року ми нарешті
відновили субвенцію нової української
школи друкували підручники які так
необхідні школярам та закуповували
автобуси щоб учні могли безпечно
діставатися на уроки окремий фокус уваги
був на зменшенні на ження для дітей які
паралельно вчаться за кордоном та в
українській школі дистанційно
продовжуємо реформу шкільного харчування
та тримаємо фокус на трансформації
психологічної служби у школах адже
піклування про ментальне здоров'я -
запорука нашої стійкості готуємо низку
змін у вищій освіті індивідуальні
освітні траєкторії зміцнення
суб'єктності студента посилення
наглядових рад та зміна принципів
фінансування закладів стійкість - це
також про українських науковців які
попри обмежені ресурси продовжують
досліджувати та винаходити Слава
Україні посилювати обороноздатність і
цього року в Україні нарешті відкрили
офіс горизонт Європа який допоможе
реалізувати нові наукові проєкти та
євроінтегрувати українську науку загалом
неухильно тримаємося євроінтеграційного
курсу і в освіті і в науці вже в лютому
презентуємо мрію освіту нової України
трансформуємо ці галузі трансформуємо
державу і за цю можливість дяку кую
збройним силам України за приклад
справжньої стійкості ви виборюєте наше
майбутнє Слава
Україні